These two equations can be solved as a system of equations if we know the
values of the area and the perimeter. Throughout this lesson, we'll usually see
the equations written like this. Here A just stands for area, which is usually
a number. And P stands for perimeter, which is also a number. But this equation
is pretty important, it turns out P will usually be an even number. And that
usually happens, since we have two ws and two ls. So if w is odd, or if l is
odd, this number will still wind up being even. So, let's take every number and
divide it by 2, since the perimeter will usually be even. So if we divide p by
2, 2l by 2 and 2w by 2, we get this new equation. Now, it may seem like we'll
have to work with fractions here. But keep in mind that P will usually be an
even number, so P divided by two will just be an integer.